So, in summary, what we discussed in this lecture was some of the foundations of
how a camera works, presented the concept of a pinhole camera, and
then basically introduced the concept of optics, and
how lenses can be used, and what role they play in ma, making a camera.
And how they used to be able to generate images that could be
stored within a camera.
What we will do now is building on these concepts, we'll look at focal length,
aperture, if you recall aperture was nothing else but
the pinhole size, and also we'll add things like what a shutter,
that is how long the opening is, the light opening is used to generate an image.
And then we'll actually talk about how sensors are used to be able to
store those images.
For additional references, I've listed two books here and
also additional material is available on some of the sites listed here, and
I'll be providing more resources on the website.
And thanks to Mark Levoy,
whose slides some of cost slide concepts were used in making these slides.